- [Voiceover] The
rectangle below has an area
of 12x to the fourth plus 6x to the third
plus 15x squared square meters.
And we can see the area right over here
and they broke it up; this
green area is 12x to the fourth,
this purple area is 6x to the third,
this blue area is 15x squared.
You add 'em all together,
you get this entire rectangle
which would be the combined
area is 12x to the fourth
plus 6x to the third plus 15x squared.
The length of the rectangle in meters,
so this is the length right over here
that we're talking about, so we're talking
about this distance.
The length of the rectangle
in meters is equal to
the greatest common monomial
factor of 12x to the fourth,
6x to the third,
and 15x squared.
What is the length and
width of the rectangle?
I encourage you to pause the video and try
to work through it on your own.
Well the key realization
here is that the length
times the width, the
length times the width
is going to be equal to this area.
And if the length is the
greatest common monomial factor
of these terms, of 12x to the fourth,
6x third, and 15x squared,
well then we can factor that
out and then what we have
left over is going to be the width.
So let's figure out what
is the greatest common
monomial factor
of these three terms.
And the first thing we
could look at is let's look
at the coefficients.
Let's figure out what's
the greatest common factor
of 12, six, and 15.
And there is a couple
of ways you could do it.
You could do it by looking
at a prime factorization,
you could say alright,
well 12 is two times six
which is two times three,
that's the prime factorization of 12.
Prime factorization of six
is just two times three.
Prime factorization of 15
is three times five.
And so the greatest common factor,
the largest factor that's
divisible into all of them,
so let's see, we can
throw a three in there.
Three is divisible into all of them.
And that's it 'cause we
can't say a three and a two.
A three and a two would be
divisible into 12 and six,
but there's no two
that's divisible into 15.
We can't say a three and a five
'cause five isn't divisible
into 12 or six; so the
greatest common factor
is going to be three.
Another way we could have done
this is we could have said
where are the non-prime factors
of each of these numbers.
12 you could have said, OK I can get 12
by saying one times 12
or two times six
or three times four.
Six you could have said,
let's see, that could be one
times six or two times three.
So those are the factors of six.
And then 15 you could have
said well one times 15
or three times five.
And so you say the greatest common factor?
Well three is the largest
number that I've listed here
that is common to all
three of these factors.
So once again, the greatest common factor
of 12, six, and 15 is three.
So when we're looking at the
greatest common monomial factor
the coefficient is going to be three.
And then we look at these powers of X.
We have X to the fourth.
I'm using a different color.
We have X to the fourth,
X to the third, and X squared.
Well what's the largest power of X
that's divisible into all of those?
Well it's going to be X squared.
X squared is divisible
into X to the fourth
and X to the third and of
course X squared itself.
So the greatest common
monomial factor is 3x squared.
This length right over here,
this is 3x squared.
So if this is 3x squared,
we can then figure out
what the width is.
If we were to divide 12x to
the fourth by 3x squared,
what do we get?
Well 12 divided by three is four
and X to the fourth divided by X squared
is X squared.
Notice 3x squared times 4x squared
is 12x to the fourth.
And then we move over
to this purple section.
If we take 6x to the third
divided by 3x squared,
six divided by three is two.
And then X to the third
divided by X squared
is just going to be X.
And then last but not least, we have
15 divided by three is going to be five.
X squared divided by
X squared is just one,
so it's just gonna be five.
So the width is going to be 4x squared,
plus 2x, plus five.
So once again, the length,
we figure that out,
is the greatest common
monomial factor of these terms.
It's 3x squared.
And the width is 4x squared
plus 2x, plus five.
And one way to think about
it is we just factored
this expression over here.
We could write that.
Actually I wanna see the original thing.
We could write that 3x squared
times 4x squared,
plus 2x, plus five
which is the entire width,
well that's going to be
equal to the area.
That's going to be equal
to our original expression:
12x to the fourth power
plus 6x to the third
plus 15x squared.